you're going mystical on me like
basically we start this way when you
were 10 years old did you ever look in
the mirror yeah okay you didn't look
like you look now Okay small he looked
different but wasn't you looking
it's it's you
like that Consciousness is there all the
time it's just aware of different egos
it's aware of different likes and
dislikes and personalities but you were
there you were there the whole time
right so we start there is that that is
what they call the soul that's what they
call the ottman they got all these weird
names I don't like oh the self okay I
like to say you are you in there hi okay
and now now the question becomes what's
what you asked which I don't normally go
there but what's the relationship
between your Consciousness and my
Consciousness well Consciousness that's
like saying if I stand on one side of
the ocean and you stand on the other
side we're looking at the same ocean
okay Consciousness is a is an entity
isn't uh Nate has a nature which is
awareness and your awareness is aware of
different things than mine but awareness
is awareness and that's where you were
going where awareness is all the same
every you know it's the most magical
thing in the whole universe awareness
right you can say all these things are
neat but if no one's aware of them they
mean nothing
okay do we share do we share part of
that awareness together is that lacka is
that when you let when you when you get
past separateness then do we share that
awareness together
there is an ocean there is a universe of
undifferentiated awareness that is
looking down through your eyes through
my eyes through every single that's the
Oneness
that's that's when it wouldn't it be
nice
for example and imagine all the people
understanding that there's a commonality
amongst all of us
we're all aware and we're aware of
different things
is this separateness innate to our Human
Experience or is that something that
we're meant to transcend
well you're deep are you okay
I don't even throw a race car driving no
well you know my agent described me the
most accurate way possible that I didn't
even realize and this is this is another
conversation another question we could
get into but people show us who we are
it's hard to see us but he would say he
would describe me to sponsors to
companies to give me money and promote
their products and he would say racing
is what she what she does but it's not
who she is well that that's everything I
teach right you go deeper you're not
even your personality right not your
preferences you're the one that's aware
of those don't you change your mind
sometimes of course but it's still you
yeah exactly you in there that oh maybe
this maybe that no yeah there's one
Consciousness and being aware of all of
that so basically to me what I've
learned is that the most meaningful life
is to grow what does that mean to notice
that
there's stuff going on inside you that's
not so much fun for you or anybody else
okay can you raise above that can you
change not much I don't like to change
that but change your seat of awareness
so I can look at this part of me that
you know just silly okay I don't want I
don't give that up all right but if I
suppress it then it really becomes part
of my personality so you don't suppress
things well if I express it to let it
out then I'm dumping on somebody you
know I don't know what you said to me
don't you talk to me like that okay I
get that well what if I step back and
say I am aware that this is upset in
here I'm aware that this inner thing
where I live my house is it's got a
little tornado going on there all right
can I just relax and step back and be
aware I'm not denying that it's
happening but it's not me I'm the one
who's looking at it and something very
magical happens if you do that enough it
releases the energy to go to a higher
level like we hold you know if you get
upset but you don't want to the best you
do is push it down right we have that
tendency with hands inside don't we
right with hands inside like no push
that aside all right which is a form of
suppression you can instead learn but it
takes time but you learn to relax in the
face of all that and what you'll find is
it's all Just Energy being disturbed and
if you give it room it will go up
instead of down or out it will go up
it's called transmutation the energy
transmutes and it could start as anger
but it comes up as love finishes when it
finishes passing through instead of
hitting you and your will in there then
it shoots out it actually has the
ability to go up and if you do that
enough times
you're ecstatic you're becoming static
literally the energy goes up all the
time not just when things are the way
you want them to be you just relax and
the energy feeds you from inside and
there's this this River if you will of a
flow of really beautiful energy that
feeds you day and night and that is the
purpose of Our Lives is to evolve we've
already evolve you know we have tails
and we got two arms and two legs and
fingers opposing thumbs we've evolved
pretty good outside all right good girl
you revolved pretty good outside but
what about inside yeah we can't handle
anything we're supposed to be the
highest species of the planet which is
called adaptability right but we're not
very adaptable inside are we right we're
very seriously pattern making machines
that's right what we like and what we
don't like and we're serious about that
and you better behave the way I want you
to or I'll you know you'll pay for it as
opposed to it's just a something that
came in or something that you said or
something that I thought you said and I
don't have to be like that I can relax
and then I can come with Clarity and
deal with the situation from a higher
place and that to me is the purpose of
life it's to evolve inwardly are we here
to experience the separateness as part
of being human or are we meant to
transcend it it's that we're meant to
witness it and not let it become a part
of us everything is a part of you and
I'm sure you've seen that okay
especially as you've grown through the
years right there's all kinds of stuff
in there right there's all kinds of
stuff in there what do we want to feed
and pay attention to and build okay as
we're growing so the first thing you do
is you you look at your person well
first thing you do is you look at your
body am I eating reasonably you've
already done all that okay you go
through that Basics if I'm eating food
that's making me sick it's silly okay I
better be strong enough to be able to
rise above the tendency to you know eat
junk and to smoke and to drink too much
and Etc et cetera right if we don't do
that it defines our life yeah you're
saying that the body will then Define
our life the illnesses and discomforts
of the body okay so let's say but notice
it took Will and it took the willingness
to rise above the tendencies that the
habits that the body has formed okay so
the question you said is even with
dealing with your body which you know
most of us have done pretty good with
that at this point all right and you
would be where you are in life if you
hadn't all right so basically you write
there you use word rise above it you
rise above these Primal Tendencies to to
eat and lust and just go crazy over
you know basic biological things all
right and so you rise above that but
then you have this ego inside that
develops patterns of what it likes and
what it doesn't like and who it likes
and who it doesn't like and how you're
going to treat me how you're not going
to treat me and I don't want to get I
don't want to get old I want to look old
I I love when people do that or I don't
I don't want to look old I want to look
like I look now what was your best year
is 23 then when they ask you to go to a
conference that's the picture you send
out there even though you're 80 or here
right and so you develop this ego inside
a self-concept that says this is who I
am right well you can rise above that
and how you don't deny it you don't
suppress it you don't dislike it you
just say Where's that going to take me
like some people say I don't want to die
well I'm sorry every single thing that
was ever born died it's a one-to-one
correlation it's amazing all right so we
did a statistical study it was a hundred
percent of everything was born died so
to say I don't want to die what a
ridiculous thing to do with your life
that's like disappointment well you'll
be uptight all the time you'll make
yourself sick just like the body things
if you don't take care of them if you
notice here take care of yourself
psychologically inwardly what I call
your inner being you're gonna make
yourself sick and then you'll have to go
out and compensate for that by doing
things that make you feel better I was
everybody says I need this in a
relationship I need this I need money I
need things I need education or what I'm
not okay
I'm not okay inside I'm not whole I'm
not complete all right and so basically
I need to get things outside to
compensate for what's wrong inside
because spirituality says and what I've
learned over 50 years of doing this this
thing is why are you not okay inside
you've learned how to have your body be
okay reasonably not always but
reasonably right why is it not
reasonably okay inside to where you feel
love all the time sure you can share it
with somebody but wouldn't it be nicer
not to need them to be a certain way for
you to feel loved but for you to feel
love and you share it you share it I'm
far more consistent it's it's cleaner
all right for both of them and you
and you realize that's true of
everything so there's a there's a state
inside of ourselves
where we have risen above we talk about
Primal biological well there's Primal or
basic psychological okay I need things
I'm not okay I feel insecure I need to
prove myself I need to be treated a
certain way I just over and over and
over you've built this self-concept of
how thing how I need to how things need
to be for me to be okay how's that
that's right right hasn't everyone done
that how do things we all do I mean we
all do at times or all the time okay
well since there's only one world out
there and every one of us has a
different idea how it should be I wonder
why there's so many wars and divorces
and everything else that's why right
it's inevitable okay and so you get to
the point where you realize I can do
better than this just like you can do
better than smoking or hurting your body
but by not taking care of it I can take
care of the inside better than
compensating and expecting the world to
make me be okay when I'm not okay and in
fact no no I'm not okay I I'm making
myself not okay I don't know how many
can love me I've never really felt that
real and I don't trust and so on I hope
somebody finds up they can plan shows up
they can overcome that
you're in there telling yourself you're
not worthy of love you made all your
mistakes in your life and so on oh I
wonder where my soulmate is how you
define your soulmate somehow the person
that when they show up in my life
overcome everything I did to screw
myself up
can you relate to that do you understand
that of course yeah relationships bring
it up the most okay and what what I call
spirituality but that the evolutionary
the real evolution is why can't I be
whole and complete Within Myself all
right can I be that's the first thing
and what you're gonna find out if you
work on yourself is the only reason
you're not
is because your Consciousness is looking
at garbage it's looking at insecurities
looking at jealousy it's looking at need
it's looking at preferences looking at
desire it's looking at fear isn't it
because that's what it sees in there so
therefore you think you are fear and you
are insecure and no you're not you're
the Consciousness that's aware of these
things well what would happen if you
paid more attention to your
Consciousness your awareness of being
and that's what the great ones have
found you happen to be ecstatic you
happen to be the most beautiful thing in
the whole world you happen to be what
the Bible means when it says man was
creating the image of God
okay that there is this beautiful being
who's you your real self looking at
garbage not always garbage
it could be nice all right but it's very
conditional isn't it hey man there's a
lot of garbage in there I give you that
[Music]